thank you
[Music]
welcome back everybody to another lovely
episode of careful boys we have with us
today a special guest his name is Kevin
Quan
[Applause]
Bart's brother little brother there it
is nephew
so Kevin Quan we're in an interesting
situation here so Bart was supposed to
be here and he was kind of going to be
the person to sort of like the middleman
he is on this and go yeah this is Kevin
Kwan he's my real estate agent right was
until he moved out to Vegas until the
great betrayal
so I mainly Bart was going to be here to
kind of give us a background on like
yeah Kevin's this guy he's really cool
blah blah instead we know none of that
and we are now cold meeting you awesome
as we started rolling which is a really
interesting thing and something we don't
get to do very often cool yeah so um
hi
I'm Anthony
go ahead what do you who cares about you
what do you do
uh as you guys probably know maybe
before I gave a little bit of an
introduction I've been in the real
estate business for 17 years wow nice so
it helps bar and geo with their first
house here uh Monterey parks and they
moved did they tell you it was going to
be there forever home they did
everything [ __ ] Liars they say
forever hope everybody says that though
it's hard to trust them now huh yeah a
great betrayal
can you tell us a couple ways why Bart
is your worst client
in like this game you know he changes it
but he's very definitive both of them
are very definitive on what they want
though uh but I think it's very common
in in uh in the real estate world with a
lot of buyers that was like the most
annoying thing that they changed
well the first one was pretty easy to be
honest with you they knew they were
going to move into that community and
there's one unit there and they got that
unit uh Second Time Around because they
didn't have to really find a place real
quickly because the the first time
around they were living in downtown L.A
so they had only so so many days or
months left on their lease before they
had to leave uh the second time around
it was much slower just because they
were patiently looking for the forever
home right yeah was that the Glendora
one that was a Glendora one yeah so I
mean we kind of went back and forth we
went looking at old houses so they could
remodeled we looked at old houses that
were remodeled But ultimately their
style is brand new homes as you can see
with every house that they've picked so
far
brand new forever homes how did Bart
find you did he just like see your name
and said is this I'm
a little brother
we gotta edit that one out make sure the
story's clean
Bart find you did he just like see your
name and said I'm his little brother
no I don't know
mitchelly oh yeah yeah yeah so the
Godfather of modern Park yeah Godfather
of the show uh used to be mayor of uh
Monterey Park
um I was heavily involved with uh our
Real Estate Association and he did a lot
of the financing for the properties that
the association had
um so I got in really close with him and
then one day he reached out to me he
said hey look I know these YouTubers
they're looking for a house when you
heard YouTubers were you like oh I'm
gonna make money off these fools these
idiots no know I had no idea to be
honest with you who borrowed you were at
that time so I kind of like Googled them
and I was like I mean okay if it works
it works right
oh but yeah we met clicked it was cool
got them into a house here pretty
quickly and
here we are nice that was like I think
2015 Maybe 16. so it's been some time so
we were talking about uh real estate
before you showed up and you know we
just want to keep it real with you out
of respect sure brother brother you know
Asian brother bro you're cool too oh
sorry guy yeah but uh you know unlike
Bart and Geo and stuff like we we're not
quite the demo that like buys like 12
houses a year and stuff like that uh
we're actually in the demo of like we
made rent this month you know what I'm
saying waiting for that one living at my
mom's did you get the lotto ticket um
but that being said our questions are
Endeavors towards real estate might be
like you know not as deep in the
professional realm yeah um but we we are
curious about some stuff you don't mind
fire away yeah
just a couple curious things like well
also like what is like your uh field of
specialty uh and that might be a very
ignorant question but in real estate
like what is it that you're like I'm
pretty good at this yeah so I mean I've
been doing this for 17 years residential
real estate is my my specialty I will
venture out I got a couple investors
that do either like multi-family retail
centers but I tend to shy shy away from
that like heavily like just doing
strictly commercial so residential buy
and sell has always been my primary all
right so I'm asking just like kind of
basically like let's say you're trying
to get into like real estate what do
some of the numbers look like like how
much you know do you stand to make
flipping houses on average how much is
like the average real estate person
who's like you know going in real and
I'm sure like to sell real estate like
as a real estate agent like uh I'm
indirect like how much you make man
I believe this year so far year today
we're at like 32 homes that we've sold
our average sales price is just about a
million so you can calculate some
numbers from there you see I'm kind of
dumb online
we're just idiots 32 000
we're just dumpling
it really is depending on the deal two
to three percent is typically what our
take home our average commission is
about twenty thousand
and when you say R how many people are
in your company uh in my company so I
built a team uh I have two sectors I
have my real estate office which we have
real estate agents doing their own thing
I have a partner now uh at the real
estate office because I've just always
felt like the sales side is funner uh
managing agents and managing people is
nice yeah I imagine people suck
uh so just on my team alone we have
three uh including myself so I I run a
really small tight ship I'm not into
looking to build like these massive
teams that you see out there where
there's like 40 50 agents I might as
well just go back to running a brokerage
at that point so really all I have is
three people I have a operations manager
I have a outside sales agent I have
myself and then we have two other admins
uh one is a virtual assistant overseas
that does all my marketing stuff and the
other one is what we call transaction
coordinate coordinator so they take care
of all the paperwork uh for every
transaction that's solid you said
marketing overseas as in like there's uh
you get enough customers and clients
from overseas that are no so they handle
like all of our print marketing they do
uh a lot of our social media yeah yeah I
understand I understand this but they
just happen to be yeah they happen to be
like you ever had to fire uh agent
because he was too much of a loose
cannon you didn't follow the books he
doesn't follow the rules but he makes
tons of sales I had an old old school
agents uh this was probably like good 10
years ago I mean he was a killer way
back in the day before I really knew him
uh but he was just in just crazy
grabbing ass too much huh yeah yeah one
of those guys it's more Spain
can you like um with all your experience
now on home sales and stuff can you
almost like uh almost profile a
demographic of people where you're like
this is kind of like a dumb first home
buyer we're gonna make hella money off
this guy
totally steals only come from an
educational approach because I can come
back at you in the future huh if you
like yeah because I mean one I I'm not
gonna try to sell something that
somebody doesn't want that's just not my
my style
um I when I see that they really like a
property then that's when I'll probably
be a lot more aggressive uh but is there
somebody that's going to be like easy
picking
I mean there are certain personalities
throughout that that you can kind of
pinpoint but I I'm a firm believer you
can't sell somebody that something that
they know okay but if there is something
blatantly obvious that I would I mean I
don't want somebody to buy something and
regret it as well too so I'm definitely
going to point out the obvious just
because sometimes people do just get
very hyped up and emotional yeah yeah oh
my God this is this is it I'd be like
well there's that right there are you
okay with that and you don't ever go
like hey man come down and then you got
to make more wise decisions because
you're too hyped right now oh definitely
I mean there you always you always got
to point out for me at least you're
pointing out the pros and the Cons with
any house right like if if you knew a
house was pretty crappy but the dude
loves it and he's like I like this moldy
smell I love the asbestos I like that
there's missing a door and it's slam and
he's kind of being a dick to you and
he's like I want it now Kevin now man I
mean that hasn't
because one thing you kind of ration out
with some people they're like okay this
this makes sense you're right because my
job is also to kind of talk sense into
of course I mean like and it really
comes down to preference there are
certain things that I will love that
certain people hate and vice versa right
today's video is brought to you by Warby
Parker all right I look kind of smart
because I have these glasses on right
but the cool thing about Warby Parker is
I went on their website and I can try
five glasses for free they have a try on
home kit you could go ahead and pick all
the five that you want to see and I got
these five right here they're pretty
cool I got the Smart Guys
they're not actually called the smart
guys this is actually called the feeling
this is called the Felix
but it makes me feel like a smart guy
when I put it on
but I also got some cool guys
this one's called the Rylan
and for me I wanted to do the try on
home kit because I wanted to put it on
first see myself in the mirror see if it
works out see if it fits the bridge of
my nose the profile and all that stuff
ask my friends and family hey what do
you think and then I can commit to the
purchase if I don't want to do that I
can send it right back so Warby Parker
offers everything you need for happier
eyes eyeglasses sunglasses contact
lenses and eye exams and you could shop
with them online or in stores glasses
start at 95
including prescription lenses so try
Warby Parker's free home try on program
which I did with these five glasses so
order five pairs of glasses to try at
home for free there's no obligation to
buy it ships for free and it includes a
prepaid shipping label try five pairs of
glasses at home for free at
warbyparker.com off the record I like
there's a freeway right behind we
literally just sold a house like a few
weeks ago to somebody that bought a
property uh where the freeway is
literally behind me like so it's loud as
[ __ ] wow but are you guys okay with it
like we live closer freeway down so it's
it's no problem for me I would probably
say no that's not something that I would
buy that's how it would help me fall
asleep actually the White Noise the
White Noise the call box is on their way
about the way you sing bro exactly no
one can hear it
what's a uh
has there ever been a house that you
gave up on you're like I can't sell this
thing it's been two years like there's a
murder in it
or have you ever sold a house with a
murderer was in there no I've been in
houses where there's definitely been
suicide or there's been a murder inside
I mean they don't feel that's when you
send the loose camera wait wait wait you
said you said they don't feel right yeah
you can definitely feel the bad energy
the haunted house does that mean you
sell at a discount you walk away you can
probably get it out you should include
Sage with the purchase exactly
have you ever done that like uh haunted
houses or whatever like do you get that
question well you hear about it no no
because you know how people there's
always rumors about certain houses where
people died in and it's like do you ever
get where you're in the position where
you have to like sell this or you're
just like you just forget about it so I
mean most traditional Asians are that's
like the number one question every
single time anybody die inside this
house there is a disclosure form that a
seller does have to fill out and the
question on there is gonna state has
anybody uh passed away on the pro or has
anybody died on the property in the past
three years it's like the literal word
are the Asians asking because they're
scared are they asking because they want
a discount uh it could probably be a
little bit
most Asian people are probably asking
that question because it's just one of
their beliefs yeah you know
um I wouldn't because because if
somebody did then they're not buying the
house
um but do people want to Discount
they're probably some people that oh I
don't care I love that discount all
right
what happens in the situation where
um a seller goes I want Kevin Quan to
sell my house and then another realtor
just comes snaking from the back and
goes
you should go with me don't go with
Kevin that [ __ ] happens he sells haunted
houses what do you do in that situation
or can you do anything so I mean we have
contracts right so if like a seller
hires me to sell their property I am
locked in or they are locked into that
contract with me for whatever that
duration period so basically up until
contract signing is all they people can
shop around and stuff so I mean you can
go interview like two or three agents I
can't do anything about that but when
you sign that you know piece of paper
that basically says you're hiring me to
represent you to sell the property I
mean there is another thing for us real
estate agents we have what we call a
code of ethics so if another property is
listed with another agent I can't go
knock on that door and be like your
agent sucks
but I mean obviously not you but you
know I gotta I gotta ask like what's
some of the shadiest [ __ ] that a real
estate agent oh I mean because there's
so many right now there are I mean yeah
because everybody thinks she can make
money doing it yeah everybody's there
yeah everybody's real estate I think
that Joe he in California is like one
out of every six people have a real
estate license which is probably I think
it's like nine out of ten Laker Girls or
something and personal trainers too yeah
um but what was the question again
I got lost on the Laker Girl part
which is like the shadiest [ __ ] that
might go down in real estate or a real
estate agent or or even like what should
somebody like watch out like what are
you warning us about yeah I mean like I
I personally believe especially for all
you guys that haven't bought a house
that I personally believe in Fair
representation I think if there's one
rule that you can get rid of in the
state of California because they allow
it some states do not is I personally
believe that an agent representing the
seller should not also represent the
buyer in advance in my correlation to it
always is if you would ever get into
lawsuit like let's say you know you're
gonna sue me you don't want to hire the
attorney I'm hiring because you're going
to talk to them about confidential
things that you don't want maybe the
other side to know
so that's like my biggest thing is you
know having that like separation but in
terms of like shady stuff I mean there's
definitely been times where I feel like
I mean I haven't really presented well
there was one where we got into a
situation where literally we showed the
property
and the agent was there a guy on my team
was there and once when that happens
that typically is going to cover like
you or what we call procuring cause to
sell sell house the client had called
the agent before and what ended up
happening was the guy kind of remembered
and said hey look like you know I know
you saw the property yesterday if you go
with me I'll make sure you get the deal
done right so then I was like well one
that should be like off off grounds like
when you know that an agent has brought
a buyer to a property like you don't you
don't step over anybody's toes uh but he
did put the deal together he ended up
losing the case afterwards because I
decided to say hey look I have all the
evidence over here it's like nice what
do you want to do so is that shady yeah
I would probably say that's shady
um plus I I firmly believe there's been
situations where a cell color doesn't
receive all the offers that that they
could have gotten that makes sense right
well because then they might have
another offer that they were
representing uh you know what I'm saying
because you look there's certain certain
times when we submit officers you're
like dude we came in super strong even
during all this crazy Market or even
before all of that and it just doesn't
feel right but sometimes it just happens
and then you look at the deal because we
could see who represents who after the
sale closes and it's like that agent
ended up double ending and you're like
okay that that doesn't make sense and it
was at a price lower than what we had
submitted so did the seller even see
that and that's why it goes back to my
whole that's sad I think that's why you
should have Fair representation how
often do you feel like that's happening
like I mean it's a very small percentage
and like I think within the Asia agent
Community
um you kind of know who the bad apples
you know what I mean consumers may not
see it because they don't they don't
know too much any person last names you
got for us on here that I can't do so
see that was a fourth Walmart
do you personally enjoy watching shows
like selling sunset
no that's like boring to you yeah I mean
I just literally try to fast forward
just to the problem
majority of them are already
have a question about property oh yeah
you ever watched this one uh website
called propertysex.com we can say it
like that
I gotta say it very clearly not we were
just talking about earlier how like have
you ever gotten a situation where like
someone's trying to get a deal by like
sleeping with you oh
shh I'm not a good one I'm not
apparently I'm not good looking you know
because that hasn't happened to me or
maybe your deal is just already so good
yeah
nine and over ten Laker Girls she's like
why seduce him getting a steal
just asking if he watches
because like if you're in a certain
field like don't you have like certain
Kinks or whatever like towards a certain
like genre
that has not crossed my mind now it
happens
is the sound of a pen on a dotted line
I love the deal dude that's gotta be a
hot moment though right like like
selling a house and it's like that last
signature It's gotta be kind of like you
know turns you on right boom
a lot of it's done electronically now so
so the donkeys
in the unread email pop-up
we went through what was the very first
house you sold my parents house yeah you
sold it to your parents no I saw it
yeah they were I mean they they're like
the typical Asians they believed in feng
shui and they said this property was
gonna give them like bad fortune it like
it the time had circulated to the point
where it wasn't going to be good for
them and they're like does that mean you
didn't sell it to other Asians actually
you know what the funny thing is is that
property the person that we sold it to
they just put that property onto the
market and it's like pending right now
yeah dude is that an actual like smart
angle to take as a realtor be like Kevin
Kwan feng shui specialist you can't I
mean like some people believe like
heavily yeah yeah sounds good right yeah
you could use that to your advantage
sometimes like somebody's trying to buy
a house and you're like ah I want to
sell the other one but
the feng shui on this one's not very
good right now yeah it sounds like my
mom do you actually know a lot about
feng shui I know like the basics
um no I'm not like a feng shui Master
hey with your look you could be a feng
shui Master you could you could pivot if
you wanted I literally have no idea
that's what I'm saying it's like you
could tell I'm your master right now
he'd be like oh [ __ ] he's I know that's
crazy the whole thing it's like uh it's
like a what is it called a pseudoscience
where like it's not proven but there's
this whole like thing wait did you just
call Feng Shui pseudoscience yes oh my
God you just lost your Asian card
well I don't believe in it necessarily
but my parents believe in it and they
were like they're super like heavy into
it like certain things gotta face a
certain way the door width has to be a
certain like thing if it's off by an
inch then it's bad luck or whatever seem
to know a lot about this pseudo yeah
yeah but there's nothing you can do to
prove it you know
what there's a lot of similarities
between like you know when you think of
golden ratio and geometric things that
make sense there it kind of crosses over
a little bit in some ways dude there's
some truth to it you can't call it a
pseudoscience
well it's only it's but pseudoscience
doesn't mean it's fake it's just not
proven with regular science it means
it's so real why prove it why test it
dude
[Music]
foreign